a ver él llegó a la presidencia no como
un candidato que se había lanzado solo
por cuenta propia por su deseo personal
sino por decisión de la vicepresidenta
Cristina Fernández de kirchner
expresidenta de la nación ella fue la
que anunció la candidatura de él como
presidente y ella como Vice Y muchos
dicen aquí que la idea de una posible
reelección de Alberto Fernández de una
candidatura de la reelección de Alberto
Fernández siempre fue algo poco claro él
nunca lo había dicho explícitamente
Ahora no dijo explícitamente que
renunciado en el video de casi 8 minutos
en el que difundió esta decisión sino
que habló de que le tras la le
traspasará la banda presidencial cuando
sea decidido Quién es el próximo
presidente de Argentina el 10 de
diciembre próximo sobre los candidatos
es muy difícil está débil la coalición
en algún punto tras varios años de ser
gobierno y eso además es el gobierno del
medio de la pandemia y con las
dificultades económicas que atraviesa el
país y hay algunos nombres en danza
ninguno definitivo algunos hablan del
ministro de economía Sergio Maza él
Hasta ahora ha dicho que no que no está
pensando en eso otros dentro de la
coalición
del gobernador de la provincia de Buenos
Aires Axel kicillof Pero él dice que
prefiere ir hasta donde sabemos a una
reelección como gobernador hay otros
nombres en danza también guado de Pedro
Eduardo Guada de Pedro que es ministro
del interior algunos están hablando
Agustín Rossi que es jefe de gabinete
Les estoy dando varios nombres Daniel y
también que es el actual embajador en
Brasil hay falta de definición realmente
ese es el problema que por ahí tiene
ahora se puede decir el frente de todos
si natalio y esto seguro va a depender
del candidato final no pero más allá
después de la pandemia y una situación
económica que no mejora Cuáles son las
posibilidades del oficialismo de
revalidar mandato además con un
candidato de extrema derecha que se hace
cada vez más fuerte
es muy interesante la dificultad más
grande que le planteó a ese candidato
Javier milei al arco político argentino
es es a todos realmente no solo al
frente de todos que sea con dificultades
como todos los oficialismos en la región
que no han podido elegir
lo que está sucediendo es que le
tensiona a Juntos por el cambio que es
la oposición entre los candidatos que
están más a la derecha y más al centro
porque no están seguros Cuál será el que
definitivamente podrá conseguir en las
primarias ser el que pasa a la a la a la
disputa presidencial que se que tendrá
lugar este año en Argentina digo es un
escenario muy complejo que ha dividido
en tres el escenario político Argentino